c'est le dernier type d'équipement reçu
par le centre hospitalier privé de
l'europe au port-marly un respirateur
pour des lits de réanimation modulaire
six au total sont équipés avec cet outil
objectif faciliter la prise en charge
des patients qu'aux vide
je les sens critique nous avons
actuellement douze patients qui
nécessitent la ventilation évasive
ces nouveaux appareils la possibilité
aussi d'augmenter la prise en charge des
patients que vides admis en réanimation
ce service possède huit lits complété
par vingt lits en unité de surveillance
continue
c'est 18 de d'unités de soins continus
qu'on a pu faire cette extension de la
réanimation grâce à l'accompagnement du
conseil régional d'île de france qui
nous a permis de financer ce qu'on
appelle les ré a dit éphémère et qui
nous a permis d'équiper des lits de
soins critiques en réanimation pour
assurer la prise en charge des patients
qui le nécessitaient aussi mai 2021 huit
patients atteints du comics disney était
en réanimation
la dernière vague de contaminations à
pousser le service du centre hospitalier
privé de l'europe à renforcer ses
équipes
c'était des heures supplémentaires il y
avait des infirmières qui sont venus en
renfort de d'oubli valtaud de notre
département est actuellement le sommes
dans une situation un peu plus calme la
plupart des valeurs les valeurs anglais
on a eu aussi le variant brasilia
c'était une famille qu'est venue du
brésil la situation sanitaire semble se
stabiliser dans les yvelines au 10 mai
2021 95 personnes attendent du coc vite
sont en réanimation